all right 6 44. it's time for our
morning cup of joe this morning
this segment was previously recorded
with metro sheriff joe lombardo
before media reports he is considering a
run for governor here it is
you know we've seen a lot more activity
as of recent on the strip and downtown
which is good news as people come back
to las vegas
is metro ramping up operations again in
those areas i know you had a skill back
when the pandemic first hit
yeah i mean we during the pandemic and
the height of the pandemic we moved a
lot of our resources into the
associated or adjacent neighborhoods
and then as the casinos have slow
rolled uh they're opening we we adjust
those resources to deal with what's
going on
in the in both the fremont street
corridor and the las vegas strip
in the height of last year in the
pandemic we had a significant increase
in
assaults involving firearms so
today that thankfully has been reduced
but as we progress and and the
percentage of occupancy has increased
we're starting to see an uptick in that
particular crime so
we're paying attention uh the cops are
paying attention and
hopefully we get through the summer
without any issues um it is officially
pool season though already
here in las vegas and metro's made it a
point to address pool safety this year
is that a new effort and what does metro
recommend when it comes to pool safety
no it's not a new effort but i'm glad
you're bringing it up because it's an
important topic
because we've already had a couple
child's children
die as a result of a lack of pool safety
already this year
and we haven't even reached the hot
months um
so we we couch it or we promote it or we
educate
under the abcds so you need adult
supervision
uh first and foremost that's probably
the important piece
of this whole paradigm you know a is
adult supervision b
is barriers have some sort of barrier
around the body of water that
would help make it difficult for an
unattended child to get into the water
and
eventually drown c is take classes one
is
how to teach them how to swim and two
for adults learn cpr which is probably
the most important thing to learn
because
even if you discover the child in a
timely manner
you're able to render aid it's going to
be a wild fortnight
if calling 9-1-1 and the medical
personnel to arrive
so it's important for you to supply that
cpr
to revive the child if need be and d
is devices you know life vests
you know the tubes the foam tubes that
you
you're familiar with and cameras around
the perimeter of the
the pools or body of waters and even
door alarms to let them know that let
you know that maybe somebody's gone
outside
in that environment so it's a big deal
and
i it actually upsets me personally that
we have to talk about it every year
because
unfortunately there's several victims
associated with this particular issue
yeah and it happens so quickly and not
just the pool but also bathtubs too
so uh really good that we're bringing
this up now sheriff and
appreciate that too thank you so much
and it's great to see you have a good
week good to see you
you too if you have a question for
sheriff lombardo send it to us on our
website eightnewsnow.com
morning cup of joe is every wednesday
right here on good day